bon hier soir Donald Trump était en
meeting le premier depuis son
inculpation on en avait parlé Donald
Trump qui n'a pas manqué de moquer son
successeur d'abord en limitant
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais même pas quel âge j'ai je
n'arrive pas à le dire ça ne percute pas
j'y ai longuement réfléchi avant de
prendre la décision de me présenter je
me sens en forme
[Applaudissements]
le Stade de France est un lieu propice
au record mais celui de demain soir ne
sera pas battu sur la pelouse pour la
finale de la Coupe de France 3000
policiers et gendarmes seront mobilisés
autour du stade ces trois fois plus que
l'an dernier les autorités s'inquiètent
de l'arrivée de 40 000 supporters Nantes
dont 700 ultra pour les surveiller des
drones survoleront le stade et dans les
tribunes des grillés empêcheront tout
envahissement du terrain 24 heures avant
la rencontre la CGT motive ses troupes
au pied du Stade de France
Macron on va pas le lâcher ce
gouvernement va pas le lâcher on va
distribuer des cartons rouges et des
sifflés au public pour que voilà il paye
fasse passer le message aussi à Macron
etc 30 000 cartons rouges à adresser au
président Macron malgré l'interdiction
de se rassembler aux abords du stade la
CGT veut les distribuer avant le match
accompagné de 10 000 sifflet objectif
huer le président à la 49e minute
référence à l'utilisation de l'article
49-3 de la Constitution vu d'ici c'est
très équilibré on pourrait presque
scinder le plateau en deux entre d'un
côté ce qui n'aime pas Emmanuel Macron
et de l'autre ce qu'il détestent
d'abord je pense que vous faites une
blague pas inintéressant je pense qu'ils
font enlever la fac
de venir
on a un déficit qui est colossal on a
aujourd'hui une dépense publique vous
allez pas attaquer la chose on a un taux
d'imposition incroyable et en plus vous
rajoutez un petit peu pour ajouter un
petit peu
au mécontentement en général avec la
retraite à 64 ans donc vous êtes quand
même un drôle vous devez me dire ça
j'aime bien
[Applaudissements]
on dirait de l'huître c'est une
explosion de saveur
si la colère reste vive dans les rues et
les sondages la mobilisation s'essouffle
après 12 journées de rassemblement
depuis le début de l'année hier soir
l'opération de distribution de carton
rouge et sifflé au Stade de France n'a
pas eu l'effet escompté et comme le veut
la tradition c'est le chef de l'État qui
a remis la coupe au capitaine toulousain
à l'issue de la finale remise en tribune
pour éviter les sifflets Emmanuel Macron
qui a salué une victoire mythique et qui
aura finalement passé une soirée assez
tranquille et assez peu exposée son
image n'apparaissante à aucun moment sur
les écrans géants les écrans géants
pardon du Stade de France pendant toute
la rencontre les soldats Ukrainiens qui
sont préoccupés
3 2 1 top
et dans cette guerre et bien les soldats
Ukrainiens vont se retrouver souvent en
face de paramilitaires vous avez les
gens une anecdote en tant que alors une
anecdote mais coupable dans les pompes
alors j'ai une personne qui est venue
chez nous pour organiser ses funérailles
à l'avance c'est-à-dire que l'organisme
elle prend son cercueil et toutes les
prestations qui vont avec bien entendu
à l'antenne parce que j'ai les retours
vous n'êtes pas concerté vous êtes tous
les deux en chemise blanche on dirait
deux anges qui sortent du Paradis non
mais c'est incroyable
c'est marrant comme ça vous avez un côté
un peu gourou on a envie de vous écouter
c'est ce que je fais un peu dans les
paris chez ma secte et la personne donc
elle est pour signer son contrat en fait
elle n'est jamais repartie chez nous
il est décédé sur place
malheureusement mais non
une semaine de vacances pour ne rien
vous cacher qu'on attend avec un peu
d'impatience
[Rires]
mais on est quand même heureux de finir
en larmes
il y avait aucun symptôme
retraité
ça s'est passé il y a quelques années en
arrière donc ça a été loyer pourquoi
j'ai jamais prendre ma retraite Antoine
c'est comme ça il faut continuer passer
du temps dans la nature réduit la
tension artérielle mais aussi diminue la
dépression et l'anxiété alors comment
est-ce que cela se traduit concrètement
et bien au bout de cinq minutes pas
seulement passer dans un espace vert on
mesure une baisse de la quantité de
cortisol ce qui est une bonne chose
puisque le cortisol c'est une c'est
l'hormone du stress et qu'elle a
tendance à favoriser les maladies
chroniques et à réduire les défenses
immunitaires Nathalie Levy vous le savez
quand on est journaliste de terrain il
faut savoir garder la tête froide le
ministre de l'éducation nationale Gilles
de Robin et puis Gérard
30 minutes par semaine dans un
environnement naturel réduirait de 7%
les cas de dépression et de 9% ce
d'hypertension artérielle franchement
vous m'avez déjà gâté avec le pseudo je
pense qu'on peut pas aller plus loin
rejoins un seau d'eau en télé sur une
émission d'infos c'est quand même
rarissime
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]